the best little pup ever anytime we get
up his treats you don't even tell me go
to his cage he just goes he's like I
know if I do this I get a really good
favorite salmon treat me and Jenna are
going to run some errands and do a few
tasks because today is Matt the humans
birthday party oh man
oh bugger actual birth data all
depending on when you close I think I
might post us today how are you gonna do
that I added it and then I posted let's
go do our tasks task number one play
pokemon I'm currently a level 22 in
Pokemon I'm about thirty six seventy
about thirty to forty thousand XP away
from hitting 23 eighty five thousand
away from twenty four hey oh we can do
it we can do these kids right here they
took over a gym and I've watched him do
it I watched it go down as we drove past
it and the yellow team take it over and
I look over those two kids feels like
number two
test number three get some fruit put up
this onion keeper steamer pineapple pump
there are so many accessories from your
fruits and vegetables
have you had those before yes we need to
stay away task number four going to get
Maddie some ice cream baby boy and we
need to get some treats for Maddie as
always because we're doing some
extensive training and I'm teaching him
to actually DJ we're not doing that well
but he's only had one day of training so
far it's going it's going all right
I should probably get the hip and joint
they have frozen yogurt banana and
peanut butter ice cream he's gonna be so
excited about it
he should somehow we just end up at
another pet store we need to get Maddie
a bed to put in the back of my car and
Jenna's car in Matt's car oh look
there's keys you guys can let me catch
paws guys come get them touch balls
so I think this which one do you think
we should get then for the car bed yeah
it's perfect I'm working doing so many
things today a lot of things before noon
which leaves us plenty of time for a nap
we're now going to get the beverages in
that mug ready to drink this one
my camera died so now I'm vlogging on
the same side let's see how it looks I'm
unsure I need to get some sparkling
water tonic I don't know what do I know
about alcohol
not a lot except that I like wine but
I'm an adult I'm of age and allow
are you going to be the dancer tonight
when we've presented at the table
sparklers I'm so dizzy
fill me up okay I'm 100 silly have no
idea I got some tonic water is that what
we want that that's right
you know one
I think I've been drinking it too it's
just like a fancy version of it - we bow
up for what we don't need it in the case
you're going to just take it out of the
case you're gonna drive everything your
credit back close we go the beverages
have been acquired now we're going to go
to the party store I'm not really sure
they're gonna have in the party sir
because I kind of think this might be a
costume store or something but it says
party designer fill of you yes what
we're doing
not knowingly jello shots doing we can
we can still do that
we can do it let's do it we're making
jello shots I'll make them Martha
Stewart oh I cut pineapples now I cut
watermelon you can call me mama Martha I
won't ya know if ever go to jail then
you can she was really funny in the bed
oh my god she actually was really really
funny so I have no idea how this audio
is I have no idea what the video looks
like I've never blogged on the Samsung
phone before it looks good yeah Wow
holla they think the Samsung looks good
oh girl author Lego slippers let's just
maybe get like a Pokemon item or two and
then we should be good let's see what
they have do they have that able to see
their Pokemon balloon we'll get a
Pikachu
and an Eevee I think those are cute this
is a pink
you ever have to go home yeah we are oh
boy maybe we overestimated how big
that's why I didn't want to get yeah oh
my goodness it does you look like our
baby oh this is nice sobriety I just it
Oh up there okay we'll just like our
baby where do we park I don't know oh my
god maybe we gotta cross the street how
do we do this
can you see I see
no we've sported a wild Mattie oh he
saved us go potty
huh don't judge me it's good work I
wasn't judging well house it was how'd
you get those I'm done so easily look
NDT higher oh yeah looks good and then
we can move a little water bottles
closer together and everything will be
perfect to pour yesterday I started
teaching Maddie a little simple trick
here right wait time to DJ time to DJ
time to DJ yes good boy right sit times
a DJ times a DJ good boy time for DJ yes
good boy
you're very very good right time to DJ
time to DJ good doggie very good time to
teach a time to DJ good boy times DJ yes
good boy that's the wrong side that we
need to have your girl's life tanda DJ
good boy time DJ time to DJ yes my good
dog
I'm a good boy I'm a good boy yeah we're
done we're done I'm very very proud of
you very proud
all right guys well thanks for watching
I'm gonna finish cleaning and prep for
Matt's party and I'll see you guys
probably tomorrow hopefully when I post
the pretty video okay bye amazing
this is just the coolest thing I've ever
seen